[Music]
please welcome they're very funny
earthquake
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes pain I feel it's how y'all doing up
there it's good to be back in the ladder
I swear I've flat on Delta all the time
I want to fly Southwest but I just don't
trust it
I don't trust no airline say they gonna
take me across country with just $49
well $50 fill my tank up will you get
your gas from are you using gas I mean
it's good to be give it up for my
President Barack Obama please come on
[Applause]
rock the live was so long looked like
they was hiring but you know I stayed in
that line you know cuz I had to vote
fall and I never seen that many black
people in the line beers all conscious
of voting but we had that 1964 mentality
weighing more let nobody turn me around
I went to vote cuz you know they kept on
saying able to suppress the vote so I
open you know I went down there with my
ID my person gives the kid my student
loan paperwork even though I didn't go
to college I was gonna prove again I
said you gonna let me vote I even took
my mama down there mama telling this
beat I finally got the ballot open seen
Barack name I pushed it plus the three
more time cuz you won't count this vote
I've been watching the scandal this vote
is gone
now the rest of the ballot I filled it
out like it was a test I didn't know
none of the answers to like put a be
right down put a see right there
proposition 13 why not - is 69 yeah yeah
you know black people love Barack yeah
we do he right below Jesus
yeah is the true we love him 95 percent
of black people voted for Barack we
still looking for the other five I'm
telling you we still looking for him we
love him two dumpsters you know I'm
gonna tell you I don't know Fox News be
all Barack I don't even know why he
wanna be President
yeah they be on him I mean they be hard
on a but I'm telling he is doing the
best job he got cuz he's the best we got
as an african-american candidate because
you could have had red mouth shopping we
be an attack he's still underneath to
try mr. president we need to talk to you
give me five more seconds perm out to
him
come on Rep talk to the people I don't
know why I don't call him red mile
shopping no more I just called him out
but I wanna know how long should you be
a rim without a church
what you gonna do a sermon here there to
keep the camp but she I love my son
my son is my man I love him to death and
I don't need no DNA test to prove my son
is fine he got all his father
characteristics here in the fifth grade
he already need a tutor I put him in
private school he wasn't ready for that
so they called me other day hey we might
have to hold him back a year I like
where you gonna give me my money back
I'd be damned if I pay you to keep a
black man down with a check clear he
needed to cliff I told him he is my son
and he's the boy cuz you know I'm saying
I tell him take a shower
tell him take a bath you don't take no
bangs I run the bath what he just put
his arm and then just play five minutes
lady come outside dries I don't know
what I like get your self backing in
watch yourself up and take them Batman
drawers off I didn't know where Batman
for a whole week I gonna fight climate
feeling your blood it's fuzzball don't
pull the head no black line down the
bathtub hey I love y'all Adele thank
y'all
thank you
Oh